hello everyone and welcome back to the
champions showdown 2017 featuring Magnus
Carlsen and Dingley Rijn I couldn't wait
for the end of the match to give you the
final result as I had to make the video
a bit sooner they only finished the
first game in the five minutes section
it was a draw but I will put a link in
the description below where you can
check out all the games and all the
results so a lot of you say that I don't
really put enough games where black wins
so here is another Carlsen brilliancy
let's call it like that so we have
Knight to f3 by way II d5 g3 and the
Kings Indian attack g6 we have the
double fianchetto or the fin Kyoto
some prefer I believe in keto is correct
but pinch arrow just seems more natural
Bishop to g2 Bishop to g7 d4 c6 castles
Knight to f6 b3 now cousin castles
Bishop to b2 Bishop to f5 and c4 Knight
B to d7 and III this seems like a good a
good moment to play something like night
to h4 at the harass carlson's light
square bishop but black is actually
perfectly fine after Bishop d6 not like
it's threatening to capture on c4 and if
you capture and d5 Bishop captures this
only makes it easier for black to
exchange this strong bishop on g2 so
after an IBD 73
Knight to e4 Knight to e2
no sorry night 2 f2 d2 and now Knight d2
f6i solidifying that knight on e4 Knight
captures Bishop captures across and
offers now a trade of bishops Bishop to
h3 I think Lauren avoids this and Queen
to b6 developing the Queen connecting
the ropes and also this comes with a
with a tiny tactic of D captures on c4
as this point is now pinned the Queen
would be able to capture the bishop f3
Bishop captures on b1 rook captures on
b1 and e 6 Queen to d3 now rook F to e8
and here comes the moment
we're delivering places c5 and this is
something of white will do in positions
like this but I'm sure that after
Carlson saw this move he knew exactly
how this game was gonna go but you'll
see what I mean
Queen to c7 and now e4 b 6 now Carlson
wants to destroy this pawn chain that
ding Liron probably over pressed with c5
e 5 kicking the knight Knight to d7 and
B for protecting the c5 pawn now a5
attacking the base of the chain of
course a3 rook to b8 we have Bishop to
c3 now Bishop to f8 and this Bishop to
f8 is a very interesting move as you'll
see rook F 2 c1 and now we have a
capture son before a capture some before
B captures and c5 b captures on c5 and
rook to a3 Carlsen pins this Bishop on
c3 and probably the best move for
Dingley run here would be to unpin with
a move like Queen to d2 but for some
reason probably
leerin thought that there aren't any
threats in this position and he played
the bishop to f1 probably because the
bishop wasn't really doing anything on
h3 he wanted to improve it maybe with
Bishop e2 and Bishop d1 or who knows
what his plan was but this allows
Carlsen a beautiful move that gains a
extreme activity he plays in Knight
captures on c5 this comes over the
temple on the Queen so it's not easy to
decline this sacrifice D captures on c5
and B captures on c5 an hour to check
King to h1 and now d4 forcing that
Bishop back rook captures on b8 first
would check as now the England is up a
piece Queen captures and now Queen to c4
unpinning the Queen and now attacking
the bishop on c5 but Carlson has
everything planned out rook captures on
c3
captures on c3 and now calmly the
characters on c3 given up the Bishop on
c5
Queen captures on c5 and now Queen to be
one not allowing Liron to capture
deponents III as
this will result in Queen captures on f1
with checkmate so after Queen to be 1
Kings to G to first C to now now the
past ponies protected the thread is of
course bringing out another Queen on c1
Queen to d6 and again had England gives
Carson a beautiful opportunity to
blunder the game as if you bring out the
Queen now you get Queen to d8 check and
this is a force to draw King g7 Queen f6
check King h6 Queen h4 check King has to
go back to g7 Queen f6 check and if the
King goes to f8 again Queen to d8 check
this would be terrible for Carlsen
so after Queen to d6 Queen to d1 I'm not
allowing Queen to d8 check and Queen to
be a check isn't that ain't that the
danger is because after King to g7 there
are no more checks so Bishop to d3 again
Tingler and offers calls and the blunder
the game but Carson finds the the nice
Queen to d2 with check and now if you go
if you go to the first rank for example
King as you want now the Queen comes
into the game with tempo Bishop to f1
and now you can either capture the Queen
this is completely fine or you can force
checkmate with Queen to e3 check King G
to Quincy to check King h3 now Queen h6
check King has to go up King g4 and
Queen to a5 checkmate so after Queen -
did you check the England played King to
h3 and after Queen to h6 he resigned the
game because now the King has to go back
if he goes to g4 it's forced mate so he
would have to go back to G - and here
comes the Queen but now there is no more
threat of any perpetual checks because
after Queen checks you simply cover up
with Queen to f8 and I mean you have a
queen over a bishop a completely winning
position and of course the England
doesn't go for this
so after this Queen to h6 check I think
lerton resigned and a beautiful game I
really like this you know especially in
this point formation when this when
white pushes c5 to close up the position
then I really enjoyed this sacrifice
Knight captures
and then Bishop captures and on c5 it
always brings an interesting game and
it's a really interesting how probably
Carlson prepared all this when he went
for this rook to a3 pin so quite a game
and like I said I still don't know the
result of the match but you can check it
out in the description below probably I
will upload this in some two and a half
hours so the match will be over and
we'll see if costs and managers do to
repeat the success from the first three
sections as so far Dingley and managed
to gain one and a half point in every
section so here he has 12 games so maybe
he will be able to grab more than one
and a half point so yeah that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thankful for watching and I will see you
soon